society at the end of the day yeah he we
just weren't able to say stuff like that
out in the open and it be actually
received you know what i mean the same
way as you said but it's being called
misogynist the backlash yeah people
instantly call it misogyny misogynistic
how is that how is that misogyny is
did you say it is i said it oh you said
it why do you use that misogynistic
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't know i don't love you how
is that because it is just the
definition of not loving someone how can
you cheat on women have different
definitions of how they love each other
no no no no love is no sacrifice for you
but yeah that's what you're you're
looking at it you're looking you're
looking at it you're looking at it from
a female's point of view i'm looking at
it from who
so do men want to be cheated on them
it's not that they want to be it said
cheating's different for men and for
women because historically men wanted to
screw as many people as possible where
women had to find the highest quality
mate
and so we can't get undo our biology
just because society is different
today
and so like i've heard guys say they
would have sex with a hole in the wall
that's what you're saying right yeah
guys have sex hole in the wall and not
know who's on that a girl where a girl
they have to have something it's a corn
category isn't it yeah yeah like like
girls they have to have something and
it's like that's why men are the major
corn consumers yeah but if if you're
saying is different right and men are
the ones to do like men are to love
women right because if if you're in a
heterosexual relationship
and so women will receive are the
recipients of the love and so the way
that the man is loving the woman the
woman is telling you i am not feeling
that as love so it's like if i'm selling
something i'm going to cater it to the
person who's the consumer so let's say
with the man and the woman the woman is
consuming that love and so you telling
me that the way i i love you i need you
though okay okay i'll break that down
for you okay okay so there's a man
loving a woman okay right the way a
woman receives love you said love for a
man and love for a woman is different
right because like a man it's his his
way of showing love is uh resources time
and attention where woman is loyalty
like we love in different ways his way
of showing it
doesn't mean it's going to be received
and if there's no point me like if i had
a business there's no point me showing
things that are not going to be received
well you can you can pick who you date
but oftentimes girls pick the guy they
know cheats and then cry when he cheats
they have daddy issues i don't think
they have daddy issues they just want
they just want a very small percentage
of men
i mean even even so
sorry do you think that a manchin
instantly means that he doesn't love his
woman is that what you're saying
so if a man cheats with a woman he does
he no longer loves his woman
i would say he might love her but i
would say he's not he's not acting in
love he's not acting so what you're
saying is a man cheating on a woman
doesn't exactly equate to him not loving
her
at that very moment he's not acting in
love so i it depends on what you see
lovers
i see love is more as an action so so
what if a girl
what if a girl isn't giving her husband
sex
does she not love him
is she not acting i think if a woman is
deliberately not giving him no it's not
deliberately she just she just doesn't
know she doesn't feel like it
because remember because that's that's
how that's how that's how that's how men
receive love right mine will be no no
guys no guys nobody is going to marry a
girl if you don't wait do men receive
love through sex yeah it was women that
give um sex for love no they're they're
more bonded through sex but no man's
gonna marry a girl unless he's getting
sex out of it you tell you you say you
want to talk
no they're like okay
they're like next okay so back to the
question so i'm saying if she's not
sleeping with him would you would you
make it equal so like she's not loving
him because that's how men feel loved
i mean it
i would say i have to i have to say it
does depend because if she's if she is
ill or something but i think oh yeah not
worth it
okay so 20 20 20 20 to 25 of marriages
are sexless meaning they've had less
than sex less than once a month in the
past year yeah i think that is so so so
that's one out of four that's a pretty
big percentage so so that would mean
that would mean that but would you which
women don't love where would would the
women would the men still be happy for
the women just to put up and have sex
like dead sex just yeah
yeah okay
this is this is often like you're you're
moving the goal position okay i'll ask
you a question i'm saying is it the same
yes or no it is it is the same so you
would say it's equal then so then a
woman doesn't love a man if she's not
giving him sex
yes
yeah okay
[Music]
if a woman doesn't give a guy sex for
like
okay i'm because i'm a christian i'm
gonna say maybe in the context of
marriage because yeah like for me that's
like the the context that i i wouldn't
say i don't love um let's say my partner
because
i'm not having sex with him right now
because i would say
for me it's in the context of marriage
this is a word salad right now would you
understand i don't know if that would
this is a word salad because when i
asked you i said if a man cheats on a
woman does that automatically mean that
he doesn't love her
your man
you're engaged your man cheats on you
i'm not putting this on you by the way
but if that happened does that mean he
no longer loves you
like i said i would say no but i would
say
at that point he's not acting in line
right so the point that we're trying to
make is that
men can just like going back to the song
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't love you yeah yeah it goes
because which is male nature
as a male he can have sex with someone
and still love his woman but then men
can do that it goes back to talk about
it it goes back to the point of the
story
because man why is that misogyny you
said it was you used that word why
because how can it be how can just him
tell him
about male nature
what's misogynistic so you said that
song was misogynistic yeah yeah sorry
what's how would you define misogynistic
well you said it you said it so so
you're you're moving it again yeah you
said it no no i just want to make sure
we're both talking about the same thing
so i know what i mean when i say what do
you what do you mean i i i personally
mean it's against women okay and i just
wanted to make sure that's what you guys
mean how is that against women
can i just before you answer that yeah
the definition of misogyny is the hatred
of women
which is very dear so not the against
not being against women okay it's the
hatred of women so when people use the
word misogyny and they mean in different
contexts
as opposed to hatred yeah it's like
it's a loose i think i think one of the
the major things which really
pee me off about the generation that we
live in today is that we just use
frivolous terms yeah without just
without knowing what we're talking about
we use it because it becomes a buzzword
and we use it because we know the
internet it can galvanize a certain
group of people behind you do you know i
mean so when people use the term
misogynistic or when they use the term
patriarchal they know that those are
trigger words for certain groups of
people that will be like oh my god it's
misogynistic oh my god it's patriarchal
that means i don't like it and you can
galvanize now a group of people behind
you
we need to start thinking a little bit
more about where we use that what's a
shame
use those words as a mic drop it's
almost like right i won yeah i said oh i
said yeah he said
misogyny i ask the men a question though
yeah go for it so what if you're let's
say your daughter
was
um going through that situation and her
man was telling her listen i love you
but i'm gonna cheat on you on a regular
i would say
if i have a daughter and if she's with a
man that wasn't honest with her from the
beginning then she made a mistake yeah
right because if a man is gonna be like
that he should have told you that from
before you got emotionally involved
right so if he's now telling you that i
would have i would i would say to my
daughter listen you got involved with a
man that you didn't know
okay and so it's now for you
it's now for you to make a decision i
can't make it for you as your father but
you got involved with a man you didn't
know are you willing to to be okay with
it but you're saying that it's love so
she shouldn't feel any way she should
feel oh my gosh she still loves me she's
presenting a choice he's presenting the
situation the reality of his situation
and she has to make a choice is this guy
who's saying look you're my main girl
and i'm going to give you all of these
things and that i'm
of certain value
is this worth
this is worth it this is cool for you
you're going gonna be the one the main
girl i look for you're the main girl i
love
this might be something other side
but it doesn't mean anything
is it gonna balance out is it worth it
but
if you asked your daughter does she feel
loved in that moment when her man is
cheating but it wasn't it's not the the
statement the state but the statement
you said was that he doesn't love her
and so that that's he's not acting in
love that's why no according to you yes
okay and i think according to the
definition of love no what's the
definition no no we're not taking your
definition you can't tell a man how he
loves a man will tell you how he loves
you then he can love a man
it doesn't make sense if the woman is
what i'm saying is it's the woman
receiving the love so you tailor it it's
like whatever audience
but you're but you're so you're going to
men you're you're but you're as a woman
you're going up to men and saying love
how we love yes because we love through
loyalty
how we live yes you're saying love how
women love but men and women are
different and so that's what that's what
like the modern woman does is she goes
up to men and says be women
be women
and then when men are women you don't
like them no i think you guys don't
understand me i am also saying to the
woman as well as to love as
to love the man
as he feels loved there's no point me
loving a man
in a woman's correctness
what if that man said
um
i in order for me to feel loved i would
like to cheat no no no i would like i
would prefer to have sex at least four
times a week
yeah i think the woman
but she doesn't i think if she if she's
told up front i think she should be told
that from the beginning like listen i
have a high sex drive
but i mean the equivalent of that would
be a man going up to a girl and saying
provide yeah exactly that's the
equivalent that's like that's not the
same like
what you're asking of men and you're
saying that's not love because you're
saying if you cheat on me that's not
love that's like a guy saying if you
don't pay for the bills that's not love
yeah so you're saying because men and
women are different so you're saying the
purpose of men because women might see a
man's purpose in in his purpose is to be
a provider yeah because traditionally
historically
biological roots and historically you
needed historically women picked men
that cheated
why do you think women have all these
songs about men being trashed because we
like the men that cheat
well not anybody
yeah yeah what is the big correlation
between
girls like guys who cheat because
they're like the guys who have the
capacity to cheat yes because it's
social proof they're like it's like you
know you're not going to go to a club
with no queue you know when you see the
big queue outside the club it makes you
wonder yeah eight thousand and some
women are social creatures like that
eight thousand eight thousand years ago
seventeen women reproduced for one man
wow
so yeah so it's like you can't it's 17
years ago or sorry 8 000 years ago 17
women reproduced for one man so you're
you're going up to men and saying change
your biology change it
and just and so that's that's like men
going up to women and saying provide for
me
you'll be happy if a man cheats on you
i'm not i'm not gonna be happy but i
just loved i'm not i'm not gonna feel
loved but i'm saying i'm not gonna tell
him that you not you don't love me
because you cheated but then is that man
had to make had sexy 17 women back in
eight thousand years he probably had sex
with no no no no no no no no no
but then was he but
what was was he cheating was out front
is the whole the whole issue of cheating
is the line everything that goes with it
we're not we're not we're not we're not
advocating i'm not advocating for
cheating i don't have no issues but i'm
saying i'm not all i'm saying is that
men and women are different and they
love in different ways that's my only
point go ahead i know and i agree with
you i just feel like it's just
with the cheating thing mm-hmm
it's just like it's the like it's the
lies and it's the lies and stuff that
would affect the cheating because i mean
because is it cheating if you all know
what's happening
i think about the issue here
is
that
the whole cheating not cheating but
an
external relationship to relation to the
whole situation is being presented in a
logical way and i think if it's
presented
to go in an emotional way like there's
an emotional investment and it's like
look there's a bond there's a connection
this is the situation
a girl will gravitate towards that yeah
they're more likely to go with that than
going hey look me and you we're gonna
start going out and by the way
there's about three or four other girls
i'm gonna hook up with
you know you call that
on a logical sense they're gonna say no
but in reality once there's a connection
there's a chance that they may say well
they might go along with it and i'm not
saying okay that's the way i've operated
but you can see it like with the tinder
swindler so many girls saying no no no i
never would have gone for that i never
would have gone for that and he like no
because because he presented yeah once
once they once they're baited once
they're baited and they're in a
situation i'm not talking about as
predatory in a way but
like because if criticism was a tinder
swindler was a conrad artist and anyone
in the con
needs to be baited they need to be
feeling they're approaching their dream
or whatever
and people once their
logical brain is cut off